[Inaudible].
How was I see, I don't even remember that.
I know I used to talk about musicals because I have a thing about, you know,
people say, Oh, you're transgender. You would like musical. I dumb.
It's not my thing. I like action movies.
How, how do you think? I mean, you're, you're an, I was speaking of, um,
of you being an athlete before you came over here. Ah, wow.
I think we use that word advisedly. I'm an endurance runner.
There are limpias and then I'm an injury and I just, I'm very slow.
I'm one of the slowest people in the world. People, I run these marathons.
I don't know if you've, I run multiple marathons and I've,
I've run 27 and 27 days, but very slowly,
But you know, you know, the Olympic record,
but they're almost down to two hours. Yeah. And I'm almost up to 12 hours.
See, I can do very long for one Meritor. I had interviews on the same day,
but I just took a long time.
I stopped when I talked to people and cows and dogs and cats and things.
So what I do is it's a holistic math thins.
I run what I feel like running where I want to run.
I don't run an organized marathons. I run. I just go, I'll go down there.
Just you. Yeah. It's uh, I mean, uh,
they have created their, their sports now and left, left, uh, at the top.
Um, do you think there is an age limit when it comes to sports?
No. Well, there shouldn't be,
if you were 90 and you could be that everyone and then good luck to you,
but I think the probably is, and, uh, and you know, Olympian athletes,
they're going to know where that edge is. I, you know, I, the trouble is,
I suppose, in sports when you get to 30 that's that's.
Ticking, but do you,
are you an athlete in the sense that you have the germ paranoia as well?
No. I think germs are good for you. You know, like I do the other thing. Well,
you know, Howard Hughes did this thing, you know, the,
the big billionaire in America and he was doing tissues and stuff in the gyms,
but then you don't build up the antibodies. So I do it the other way round. Um,
and I know I'm sure, you know, professional athletes,
very good Olympian athletes, they will have a way of doing it.
But what I do is eat a piece of dirt, put a piece of dirt in your food. Yeah.
Because think about it. Think about all our, you know, if you're from Norway,
Sweden, Britain, China, wherever you're from the whole world,
we've come from people who were not living with antiseptic handwash yet.
They were just living in camps and things and they were nomads and they got
through it. Didn't they? They weren't go. I've got, Oh yeah.
Yeah. I mean, they became like 30 years old.
Okay. That's a good point. Yes.
But maybe that was because they were just working so hard to say.
Uh, you, you, you're coming to, to, to Sweden and Norway, uh,
touring in the spring, uh, uh, with the, uh, show you called
[inaudible] German name.
Well I've,
I'm against Brexit hate and Trump hate and all the negative right-wing let's
separate stick our heads in the ground and go backwards for humanity.
I am forgoing.
[Inaudible].
Right. You learn to live together and work together in some shape or form.
And if you take Norway in particular, Norway, back at the Vikings,
Norway used to zip over, um, no. Is your country. Yeah. Yeah.
So you used to zip over and say, can we, uh, just kill everyone?
Like all this stuff will come and do.
A chat shows and stuff, and that's much nicer.
This is, this is the logic. And we do this and we see the
[inaudible].
The whole thing of a purity of a race is nonsense.
Cause we're all into married into together.
And our language is interlinked and it's difficult. European union,
very difficult. And they don't always not is in the European economic area,
but it's still the idea. My thing is I perform,
I develop my next show. There's wonder about show in French two to four say,
and I will be back in Paris in December, uh, doing it.
So if anyone could learn French by December,
I'll be there during the game bridge. And I do, I improvise in French. And then,
because I wanted to redouble my office and this is all because of Brexit and
Trump. Oh.
Because if half of my country is going backwards and I'm going to go even
further forward. And I, I translated what I developed in French into German.
I went to a free, the stretch to in Berlin and I did the [inaudible],
which was Zeshan and that sphere at the same time. So,
and then I translate it into English and I'm doing Spanish as well.
And I want to do Russian and I want to do Arabic, but no Russia,
you don't speak Russia. No, at the moment I say, uh [inaudible] and uh, the,
the hello in Russian is really tricky. Um, uh, it's much bigger,
but previous is high. And I know that one, I know specific,
specific bok choy cause Bolshoi ballet is the great ballet and specific Porsche
is, is thank you very much.
Same liquidity. Is this your level? And this is my level of exactly what.
It's a tricky one, but, um, you know, German is a tricky one for me,
but it was the all Russian kids speak Russian or Mandarin.
Chinese could speak Mandarin Chinese know languages that hard.
Yeah.
What is this? I mean, it learning a language. Yeah.
Is that about a talent or is it about.
Determination? Motivation above all motivation.
And I can prove that anyone can learn a language. I've got this great proof.
It's a logic proof. Um, someone says, I can't learn. Learn, no, no, no, no, no.
We tried a million times. So I say, what do you want to learn? They say Spanish,
they manager, whatever I say, let's go there for a weekend. And then as you go,
I'll tell you to go ahead through customs.
I'll just slip a block of heroin into your bag. That's smuggling heroin.
That's Miami heroin. They go to prison for 10 years to life.
And within one month they're doing basic sentences.
In the Spanish in general, whatever is because the motivation.
Will be, I better learn this language.
Die and.
It's just motivation. And everyone goes, Oh yeah, I suppose so.
But because I came out as transgender 33 years ago when we were all children,
um, and I got no front cover of any newspaper at all. Uh, I, what I did, uh,
because I can set up artificial emergencies, I can set up, uh, you know,
back in 85, there was no reason to,
as a straight transgender person to come out, I could have lied.
Like people have done throughout millennia going backwards. And I thought, no,
I'm the right person. I wanted to be in special forces.
I didn't go to special forces. So I did the psychological, you know,
civilian special forces of coming out and taking all the crap that I get in the
streets that I get less in the streets these days. But you know,
people shouting me, people fighting me. I will deal with that,
but this is a better place I've got to.
And then people are more relaxed these days in all our countries in always,
we didn't really get that. Everyone's more relaxed.
Did this, this, this is also about determination. Yes.
It's a decision that you made.
Yeah. I'm a determined little bastard. Yeah. When you, when you,
when you're working, I mean.
Uh, talk, talk about enduring pain. I mean, it's, it's, uh, eh,
the way you work is that when you preparing for a tour now yep. Uh,
you go on stage here in London. I saw you the other night. Uh,
and it's like, incredible because you, you walk on it, you just start talking.
Yeah. Uh, uh, and, and part of is of course you,
you get a huge loss and some material,
you just make a little note that this does not work. Uh,
how much pain can you endure? Uh, well.
I don't think that's painful. It's like you, when you're doing,
remember your first ever chat show that you did,
that was probably pretty painful now. Less painful. Yeah. It's,
it's the pressure. It's what happens. It's like driving a car,
driving a car is a very good example. When we learned to drive a car,
it was a nightmare.
And we're going to hit a human that CA a dog we're going to hit another car.
Remember that those times were as well. Oh, hang on. I would stole it,
stole all that pressure. And now we do it for three hours ago. Yes.
I know what you mean. Yeah. What I then, so.
Anyway.
We will have these conversations. We'll fiddle with the radio, but stuff up.
Yeah, I know. Sure. Hang on.
We're pretty good.
In that car thing, but that's an amazing thing.
As you track back through humanity,
there's no reason we should be able to drive these mirror signal, maneuver,
you know, two ton vehicles, but we can do it. So the pressure gets less.
That's it? So as you saw me last night and the night before it was, uh, I'm,
I'm not bothered because if I can do it in French, if I can do it in German,
if I can improvise in German, that improvising in English is like through,
you know, that's, that's the trick. I make things artificially hard for myself.
And then I get a gift of easiness back up the ladder in English. You're.
Talking, you're talking a lot about religion.
We, I don't believe in religion. I mean, I understand you talked a about it.
It's great. It's a great area to go for. I will probably do that. The thing,
which is,
I've only just discovered this in the last few days that no animal has religion.
Um, you know, no tigers ever go, okay,
we're going to go and we're going to get the antelope. Jimmy,
you come in the right flag. I'll come in the left gland pink Crow.
Then we'd go through all my I'm right around. We'll all go for it. And now, uh,
Padre, if you could make a prayer to.
The gods, Timmy.
The tiger,
we going to please help us get in and get this antelope and rip it to pieces in
the most merciful way that we can, you know, that just doesn't happen. So we,
and you'd think that if a God had made us all,
he would make sure religions and all, all the animals,
all dogs should be praying every Tuesday at half four or something.
But no, they didn't do any religion world war two. Is it world war two?
That's the time he was should have come down.
If he made us all and we were praying like crazy and 50 million dying and this
idiot with a mustache, you know, and that was the time to come down and go,
what's that guy. I'm so sorry. I'm God, I'm sorry about that. Hit.
Anyway. Carry on.
That didn't happen.
So I don't think he's coming guys. He doesn't come for tsunamis.
He doesn't come for earthquakes. He doesn't come for world Wars.
He's not coming. And interestingly in Europe we have moved away.
I think from God, maybe Republicans going it's like about towards me,
but most of us are moving away. Um, in America, you still,
if you're going to get elected, you have to say, God bless America.
But in Britain, if we said, God bless Britain,
everyone would just look at you politically. They'd just go.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Even though God is still supposed to be there somewhere.
W would you, would you ever, I mean, have you, have you ever in your life,
uh, sort of hoped that there was something there? Have you, have you,
have you prayed? Uh, well, my mom died when I was six and.
Yeah, I did pray. I went to a school. We had no religion at home, but from six,
I went to a boarding school with my brother and they had a built in Protestant
church of England, kind of a light religion, not too heavy. You know,
us sing a few him and his safe things. There's a guy, Jesus, the Jew,
the Jesus guy, the Yeshua, his real name is gesture. Um, I love him.
I think he's great guy, you know, and, uh, Mohammed Mohammed as well.
They're very interesting guys. They're like Nelson Mandela, like Gandy. Um,
and they've been women as well, great spiritual leaders,
but I just don't think the floaty guys up there.
I don't think this guy who comes down and goes,
now everyone eat cheese or something. You know, I just don't think that.
I don't think he's there. I've noticed. He's not. Do you remember?
In the old days we used to say that God lives in the clouds and he was always in
the clouds.
And then we've learned to fly in the last century through the clouds and they
will never say, he's not here. He's not, not ever mentioned.
You know, they should have gotten wet.
It's not that it's not on that cloud. And it should have been.
Jesus in Abarth. They're going, I'm on just pull the curtains up. You know,
there was no one in the clouds and we always thought they were in the clouds and
whenever something gets disproved, we never make a marker on that.
We just move on and go, Oh, he's further up. He's in the stratosphere.
He's on Mars. Now he's three planets over. So I just don't believe in the guy.
Edit from, from whom did you inherit.
Sense of humor? This is dad. My dad is a great sense of humor.
He died this year. Mum died 50 years ago. Dad died this year. Um, in my show,
I tell him his final joke. He made a joke.
He phoned my brother up and told him this joke. And, uh,
but he still had the sense of humor and he was still,
they had lesions on his head because he, because he had a bit of skin cancer,
he'd been in a very hot country for eight years in Yemen where we were born.
And they said,
you're going to have to have that dealt with by a plastic surgeon.
And then he said, okay, we said, he's not actually made of plastic. Is he?
And he was still coming out with funny lines,
even though he was not having a great time of life. But yeah,
he he's the sense of humor, but my brother's got the same sense of humor. How,
how close were you as a family? Um, we were close in a kind of,
kind of slightly British way, slightly pulled back emotionally the way. Um,
yeah, there's a strong bond of love there.
And we loved our mother and mum went so long ago now, but, um,
yeah, so it was great.
And my brother said he wrote an obituary for the newspaper.
Local newspaper said, if you can't get to choose your parents,
but if we had been allowed to choose our father, we would have chosen him.
And that was very nice for my brother.
[Inaudible] similar to your father.
Yeah. Um, I will. Um, yeah, I think so.
It was quite similar. He was also really active and a hard worker.
So did he train you hard? Was he like a, this? No.
He never push us. They wouldn't push it. No. Absolutely.
He was never standing with the award shore. He drives to the training, uh,
smoking and look in the race. He was calm guy and, uh,
no pressure from the parents at all. So that was, I was really lucky.
Um, Eddie, I have to ask you before we move on here. Um, you,
you, you talk a lot about animals. Do you keep it on or are you,
do you like it?
Yes. Yes. I I'd like to feel,
I could walk up to a tiger and say hello and look him in the eye.
But I think he'd eat me.
What do you think if, if, as you are, you aren't a politician, right?
I'm going to be a politician after 2020,
I'm standing to be a member of parliament after first general election after
2020. But I.
[Inaudible], I'm sorry, but these people came about the moon.
No one, but in a spiritual way, you can,
but no,
but I think maybe the applause is not necessary because they may not know my
politics, but I'm I'm for the many, not for the view. I'm for humanity.
I'm for this century, we have a world where 7.5 billion people.
Everyone has a fair chance. That's what I'm fighting for.
And I'm trying to live it. I'm trying to live politics.
So I'm performing in French and German and Spanish.
I want to perform in Arabic and Russian.
I want to reach over to other countries and say, hi, and can you learn from us?
Can we learn from you? What can we all learn together? What can we,
we're all human beings. We come from the same place.
And I'm looking for the connections as opposed to the separations.
I think Brexit, Trump hate it's for separation for we're better than you.
That nationalism, that old thing of the thirties.
And we know what happened in the thirties. If you pick up a book,
you know what happened? So it's just not the place to go.
So I will fight against that everywhere.
[Inaudible] a thought experiment. If our,
our animals here in Britain were able to vote.
If we gave them the right to vote, where would you put them on the, on the map?
Uh, what would they be politicals? Right? Who's left.
That's a very silly question. You realize that?
I think they all vote against Brexit.
[Inaudible].
I am quite sure with my connection with the animals.
I say some of them wouldn't be sure, but I've got them. And I'd say,
Mr. Tayga Mr. Kenney, the drive. Just,
just trust me on this. We humanity. We and the animals.
We've got to do a partnership, baby. We've got to head forwards.
We've got to go forward rather than backwards.
You can't go forwards if you go backwards. So, and they would go. Yeah.
Yeah man. Yeah. The cats though. No,
not the big cats. Not even some of the small ones. Okay.
Whenever they let you down. No. Would they they've vote their own way.
They'd probably abstain. Thank you so much.
[Inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.